get ready for some serious cuteness  because Kim Kardashian just snapped  chatted with her son Saint West and we  have all the fields when I had no idea  that I was gonna end up feeling this way  the Keeping Up with the Kardashians star  got snap happy on Tuesday sharing  several selfies of herself with her  two-year-old son filters and all oh but  it gets so much better it look like a  joke there's Kim and Kanye West middle  child with a pizza crown and my favorite  the grandpa filter the reality star and  her rapper hubby welcomed their third  child into the world on January 15th via  surrogate and later revealed their  newborn daughter's name  Chicago West a source previously told et  the name has a special meaning to the  Grammy winner folks Kanye was raised in  Chicago and it's really where he started  to thrive as an artist his mother was  also very connected to the city so this  is likely in part an homage to her  [Music]